hey everyone it's Ryan I'm back and
better than ever you might recognize me
from my previous BuzzFeed video this guy
eats fruit for the first time you all
the internet had a lot of thoughts about
that honestly I don't understand like
the big problem with that video like I
really don't I stepped out of my comfort
zone and I tried a bunch of fruit that
was good I really like I hate now I'm a
changed person I literally don't just
eat fruit when I'm drinking alcohol I
have it with yogurt I have it as a snack
I have a really amazing relationship
with fruit now I'm a very dramatic and
defiant person so growing up when people
would tell me to eat vegetables
I absolutely rejected that Ryan I'm
really unsure as to how you're still
alive and functioning this has gone on
for too long it's time for you to try
vegetables I am not sure how this is
going to go for you got the paramedics
on deck it's time to grow up
[Music]
please just eat the vegetables I'm
really proud of you for expanding your
palate from any year-old to ten and a
half year olds I don't know how we
failed you I don't know what we did when
you were little right we really did try
you were so disgusted trying the food so
good luck with everything and we're
really proud of you so I can't really
say that I haven't had vegetables
totally I've had corn which I don't
really know if that even counts I've had
potatoes but no one really cares about
those like I do not eat lettuce like
I've never had broccoli I've never had
cucumbers I've never had carrots the
list goes on and on but now it's time to
go deeper I need to really push myself
I'm going to eat vegetables for the
first time
I feel stupid if I'm wrong about this is
this a green bean degree yeah I'm
nervous because it's green people are
gonna get mad at me for puffeth and half
that I don't care there's like sheep
inside of it
I don't know if I like it or not it has
like a little spiciness to it
is that normal I don't know it's just I
didn't connect with that when being in a
way that I wanted to fit no next
vegetable please this is celery I'm
familiar with her so I've been given
some lifelines here and one of the
lifelines is that I can dip it in
dressing please bring me the ranch now
why does everything smell spicy to me
here's the ranch I'm
[Music]
I don't like that doesn't taste like
anything like it doesn't have any
substance it's like water with like
crunch vacation and like I don't care
about it it's not good
is that a cauliflower I don't like that
people like you have a ranch moment with
this did i drench it
I don't like that when are you gonna
bring me something I like like this is
stuff so I know this is a beat we just
had a little juice come out
[Music]
it's not good I don't like anything so
far but tomatoes taste like ketchup so
oh they know they don't taste like
ketchup at all that's not even seeds
[Music]
it's like okay is that some you know
fruit I've never even had this Oh tomato
with Italian dressing right here hmm
tomato is definitely the top vegetable
right now the others can choke mm-hmm
carrot can I use my ranch lifeline I
feel like I've been using it constantly
do you blame me so I'm not gonna
comments if you blame me I hope I really
like these because hummus is like my
oxygen right now I know that people have
a carrot hummus moment a lot and I'm
hoping to be one of those people it's
fine I'm gonna have a second bite oh I
got coffee that's what I get for taking
a second bite
together with you and carrots maybe I'm
obsessed with it it's just like clean
I hope he's bringing me something that's
actually good this time hey snappy
excuse me snapper snacks yeah
snap okay I don't like that it tastes
like a tree I knew as soon as I bit into
that it's not for me all right this is
cucumber it smells fresh and beautiful
I'm hoping that this like deletes any
pimple I ever get
hmm that was good that is number one
taste fresh taste light a skinny my
faith in vegetables is temporarily
restored is this like the same thing
only like uglier a zucchini literally
looks like a cucumber that just like
gave up I really don't want to try this
what do I do
I'm not gonna like this Chris no I'm not
gonna like this think you're not I just
I can't do it I honestly can't don't do
this to me over these vegetables and
their smells and psychotic looks you
don't think I'm gonna like it
it's okay it's like I just think it's
cuz my bike my BA I'm not used to
tasting anything that's from earth maybe
it a couple more tries with it like I
wind up liking it the doors ajar I
thought you weren't doing anymore the
producer of this video is like that's
crazy and wants me to keep trying all
this and I'm really over him you Chris
mushroom I wish it was one of the
psychedelic ones that would get me
through this video hate the smell of
mushrooms hate the appearance of
mushrooms Heat wouldn't chicken has
sauce that's interacted with mushrooms I
want to go home
[Music]
hmm it's not bad but I don't know if I'm
I like it it's not offensive at all I'm
fine with him all right so why do you
have three plates here I've been given a
choice I'm gonna go with arugula
I think arugula also is like a sign of
wealth and power I used to work at a
restaurant and like all the rich people
with like American Express cards would
order stuff with arugula which I eat the
whole leaf
mm-hmm
okay arugula was good I feel like rich I
think the audience would really
appreciate it if you if you could also
try baby spinach maybe lettuce another
leaf this is raw
I think I like spinach better than
arugula whoa
we're that was fine I'm not having like
lettuce like I need a break I feel like
I just ran a goddamn marathon right now
I did the best I could
it took a lot if you know me from the
last video you know if this was a big
step for me so going forward I want to
try I think like a salad like with
cucumbers maybe some spinach leaves I
encourage everyone to step out of their
comfort zone and try something they ever
tried before and I'm basically vegan now
[Music]